hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well within the
fragments that we possess of the work
nature of the great pre-socratic thinker
here at cleitus one of the themes which
is a rather paradoxical one if we if we
think it out that comes up as a central
is what we might call the contrast
between harmony on the one hand and
discordant disagreements disharmony on
the other hand taken far enough into
opposition to be actual war or fighting
now with any collection of fragments
like this we could really begin at any
place and so it's somewhat arbitrary my
choice of which fragment to begin with
but I think that in order to put this
into perspective it might be best to
look at fragment 80 and that's using the
deels numbering first so he tells us
that one should know and the Greek terms
there we're going to come back to in
just a moment r8 and I pray that war is
common that strife is justice and that
everything arises and is lacking we'll
talk about alternate translations there
through strife so this is a rather
blanket statement covering a lot it's
it's saying that one ought to know
something about the nature of the
universe about the nature of human
relations about reality perhaps even
about oneself so he says that war is
common and more there is polar most some
people try to translate that as a sort
of principle of antagonism carried out
in any way but I'm in war as polar mos
and he might be suggesting that
everything is at war in some way or
another and it's good to remember that
this doesn't mean that we have a war of
all against all necessarily because when
you do have a war you don't have
everybody on one side fighting each
other you have them fighting everybody
on another side although there may be
some conflicts within there so he says
that war is common common not in the
sense of you know something that we
commonly run across but soon on here
which is kind of an old-fashioned term
by the time that we get to more modern
Greek writers and by modern I mean more
ancient but but less ancient and
Heraclitus it's something that binds
things together so to say that it's
common doesn't just refer to its
ubiquity it refers to the fact that it
is something that peoples have in common
strife eros another term for a
discordant actually turned into a
goddess you might you might remember
eros giving the Apple as part of the
start of the Trojan War strife is
justice DK so what is that supposed to
mean well in some respect
and there's another fragment that I
think helps to bring this out it means
that you don't actually have justice
just by itself in the universe
everything going along swimmingly you
get justice by imposing justice by
having sides contesting against each
other making rival claims saying this is
justice no this is justice and what
you're doing is wrong no what you're
doing is wrong and sometimes having to
come to blows about it or to submit it
to a judge now this other part
everything arises another translation
for this is everything happens in
accordance with strife and necessity now
the term there kreyòl men dah okay that
that could be translated as things that
are necessary because creo gives us the
fray which means it is necessary by that
by the time of Heraclitus that's already
sort of a common Greek way of using that
that verb and but it also does have the
sense of being something that is that's
not there that want to be there
something that is lacking and I think
that fits really well with the
everything that arises or another way of
translating and everything that happens
genome and I it's as this dynamic verb
and then everything that's that's
missing all of that happens in in
accordance with or through strife
kakoton right so what we've got here is
something that a person if they want to
be one of the wise really needs to know
if they want to be one of the dummies
the many according to Heraclitus who
don't really know anything and just kind
of wander around doing things that
random saying and doing you know foolish
things that that could they could be
doing differently then don't worry about
this but if we want to really understand
reality then we need to take a look at
this according to Heraclitus now I
mentioned there's another really
important
and this is fragment 53 one of the most
famous ones of Heraclitus I think where
he says war is father of all and king of
all so war has this superlative status
why he gives some reasoning for this
following this he says some war reveals
as gods others as human beings some war
makes slaves
others free so there's a revelatory
capacity to war to pull the most to this
this striving against each other
this agonism or antagonism if you like
so these I think go together in order to
understand things we have to see what
the conflict of forces against each
other
reveals to us rather than just taking
things you know on the basis of their
names or preconceived notions and I
think there's a really interesting
example of how this works in a
cosmological and also to some degree I
guess you could say theological way in
the passage where he's talking about the
Sun how the Sun does not overstep its
its bounds
why not here we go this is in deals
fragment 94 the Sun will not overstep
and it's literally the word is is you
know got by known stepping in it it
won't overstep its measures and measures
here are you know quite literally Metra
the Sun has its ordained place and it
won't overstep it why not because if it
does it's going to provoke conflict and
it's going to run into the Furies who
are allies epic ooh Roy another way of
translating that mercenaries or you know
retainers or whatever of DK of just
so justice if the Sun gets outta line if
the Sun does more than it ought to you
like goes too close to the earth or
decides it wants to sleep in one day or
something like that then the Furies are
going to get after it and the Furies are
you might say they're very much in
alignment with Eris with strife right
they are the ones who come in and stir
stuff up and impose inflict upon others
so I think that's that's enough about
that sort of cosmic process in principle
another thing that Heraclitus gets
talked about quite a bit for is this
metaphor of the harmony that is involved
in the lyre or the bow so a bow I think
everybody is familiar with that you know
you have a string and you have a wooden
piece could be composite back then
probably not and you pull it back and it
sits two forces that are you could say
in harmony with but also differing from
each other and you use it to propel an
arrow which then uses the force of both
of them and you know shoots out against
an enemy or hunts something or maybe
you're doing target practice whatever it
happens to be a lyre is a musical
instrument and the Greek lyre was kind
of bow shaped and I think you've seen
images of them and I have a thing across
the top and then you hit all these
strings that you had tighten up and the
strings themselves are in a scale which
is it played in certain ways can give
you harmonies now typically they would
pluck the lyre they weren't playing
chords all at the same time they're
playing what we typically would call
today arpeggios but it's still the same
idea and he tells us this is in fragment
51 and deals that what we have with the
lyre or the bow is a back turning
harmony and the word he uses for harmony
there is your the one that we trans
literate hormone EA and bad turning
pollen Tropos what does it mean
be back turning harmony and how do you
have a harmony with a bow so harmony
here doesn't just mean musical harmony
it means some sort of accordance it
means some sort of things balancing each
other out and producing something else
as a process whether it's the musical
notes or the arrow flying or whatever
whatever we could have all sorts of
other examples why is it a bad turning
harmony well he tells us that what
people don't recognize and the word that
he uses there in Greek is from the verb
soon ami meaning to understand to
recognize to see they don't recognize
that there's two things going on at the
same time and here's where it gets quite
paradoxical we have a tending of ways
how its translated but the Greek is
actually dia federal men on the word
that we get differing difference from
later on right
the dia federal Menem would be the thing
that differs from something else and but
but literally it does mean tending away
or being carried away right but it's
also in agreement homologue a right so
how can a thing both be tending away and
or differing and also in agreement well
like the lyre or the boat so these are
being used as metaphors for how you know
the cosmos works how human relations
work and what this means is that we can
talk about on the one hand difference
and discordance particularly that of
fighting and more and also harmony as
not being entirely dis harmonious with
each other so we might say that there's
an even greater overarching whatever we
want to call it harmony connection some
sort of principle uniting these together
and that's difficult to wrap our heads
around difficult to think this is a
paradox indeed the only thing that he
says that's particularly interesting
about this is not in that passage it's
in fragment 54 where he talks about
harmonies as being not apparent and
apparent meaning harmonies that we
readily see as harmonies and harmonies
that are to some degree concealed we
have to look into them so often ace and
fauna Ron are the two terms that he's
using there and those come from the word
suits who actually appear to somebody so
what's really interesting here is that
he uses another term a value term create
Shawn and this is a very common value
term in Greek and it's it's rather poly
Simmons it has multiple meanings
it can mean better as in you know
superior in value but it can also mean
more powerful then and I think in the
time of Heraclitus we can make a good
argument that he's actually playing on
both of these and we might say well
non-apparent harmony is not just better
in some sense maybe aesthetically or in
terms of grasping things intellectually
but also ontologically or metaphysically
is more important more prior so that
even in the war we can see some sort of
non apparent harmony going on in that as
well there's a few other things to say
about this this theme one is that he
notes an interesting function to
discordance to a lack of harmony which
might conceal a you know not apparent
harmony so one thing that he tells us
and this is in fragment 111 is that
contrasts make things seem Pleasant or
good and he says that here we go he
precedes this in 110 by
it's not better for men to get
everything they want literally
everything that they they choose
everything that they they plan for
themselves telling why so he says
disease makes health Pleasant he doesn't
actually say is it as the translation
here says Pleasant and good because the
next thing that follows is bad good
literally
kakoen Agathon so it could be read as a
general principle that the bad leads us
to recognize the good
so disease makes health pleasant meaning
like when you're no longer sick you're
like oh man I feel so good right now I
could go do a million different things
right and we can say this about other
things as well that he gives as examples
hunger makes you know being full
Pleasant or good weariness makes rest
similarly Pleasant or good so what do we
have here how does this tie in with
strife and harmony and all that well you
know the fact that we have these
opposites allows us to recognize the
better thing as the better thing he also
says something kind of funny that you
know maybe fits in with the way it works
for the many but even the wise as well
that blows Drive animals to pasture
going to pasture is not something
automatic for sheep or goats or cattle
you actually have to drive them to go
out there and blows could be something
within strife you could look at what the
Shepherd does is not this this wonderful
harmonious pastoral thing but if you've
ever handled the animals you know that
things often don't work that way alright
the last thing I want to bring up is a
very famous passage an enigmatic passage
that is often quoted in discussions
about anger by Heraclitus and it's often
translated using the term anger here's
here's a
and translation of it in this one here
we go
the reason it is hard to fight against
passion is that it buys what it wants at
the expense of the soul so passion anger
both of them are ways of translating the
the Greek term sumos which was felt
literally here in the chest Homer uses
this term quite a bit kilise has to
master his through most in order to not
you know kill Agamemnon where he stands
and this this gets discussed but Plato
turns it into a part of the soul by
Aristotle who makes it one of the main
kinds of desire or aspect if ax t
literally what Heraclitus says is a lot
more straightforward who most maka sigh
ha the poem who MOS is that that drive
whatever we want to call it
Maka's thigh is the word to fight
against tied in with battle polo Mo's
right tied in with strife Maka's thigh
is is sort of a term that signifies a
conflict within the person you feel what
your thumos wants and he actually uses
the term through most wanting something
right and he says it's difficult Hal
upon a hard thing to do it's a difficult
thing to do to struggle against one's
own anger desire why because what it
wants it will purchase even at the cost
of one's life it will throw one into the
battle so we come full circle through
most is part of this and Heraclitus is
noting that this is part of ourselves we
might actually want to bring it under
control so we're not the ones who are
willy-nilly fighting battles but rather
choosing the battles that we want to
fight and perhaps along lines that
produce some non apparent harmony so
this is a very rich theme well worth
exploring obviously if we had more of
here
colitis fragments there might be more to
say about this but that's that's what
we've got for the time being
you